oh hi everybody Chris color here with
wired.com here with wired magazine's
Chris Baker we are still at e3 in the
middle of the show floor which chris is
just as noisy and just as kind of
glaring but a lot smaller than in
previous e3's now it's not as noisy as
previously freeze there used to be a guy
walking around with a decibel reader
demanding that people turn it down
because it could cause deafness it's
smaller it's quieter may not be able to
tell from looking but it's a shadow of
its former self it really is grace you
know III this year it's really just
about company showing off what they're
going to have for the holiday season in
many respects games that have already
been announced but still a lot of fun
games on the show floor even with e3
being downsized what so what's one of
your best games of the show so far the
new Prince of Persia looks really good
it has a great art style yeah the
control scheme is a little different
from the last games but just as rich and
innovative I think a lot of people will
like it I really wanted to talk about
rhythm heaven for the Nintendo DS it's
based on a Game Boy Advance game that
only come out in Japan but the DS
version coming to America they did not
show it at their press conference and
but it really is a very fun music game
that hardcore gamers I think are really
going to enjoy you guys should
definitely check that out yeah we just
got the slightest little hint that
there's going to be more portal but all
valve is showing here is left for dead
and that's plenty left for dead is a
fantastic sort of mix of survival horror
and a straight-up shooter game it is
incredibly fun very very scary
everything that resident evil 5 is
trying to do left 4 dead pulls off
I also really had a great time today
checking out of course rock band 2 we're
going to bring you guys more information
on that in the coming weeks but we got
to play there $300 super professional
drum set that works with the game and
has like four drum pads and three
symbols you can really rock out on that
thing and I think both of us were really
pleasantly surprised by Peter Molly news
fable to all the great promise that we
saw in the last playable game really
seems to be coming together in this new
one it's a it's looking really
impressive now the big designers are
still here just today we spoke to Peter
Molyneux we even sat down with Shigeru
Miyamoto Nintendo to talk a little bit
about his upcoming games so in that
respect you know III is still the place
creepy movers the Shakers of the
industry but not a whole lot of console
wars talk Chris Baker yeah it was a very
subdued presentation from all three of
the the victory console makers Sony's
basic message was we may not have the
goods this year but you know we're going
to still be there plugging in 2013 2014
Nintendo's message we don't even need
you hardcore gamers anymore we have the
casual gamers and Microsoft's message
was we want all of you hardcore casual
buy the xbox 360 please Activision
actually pretty much skipped this year's
e3 because they left the entertainment
software association that puts on e3 but
they had their own event in which they
showed off some of their upcoming games
like guitar hero world tour and the new
castle wolfenstein and James Bond and
all that kind of stuff yeah and i would
say in this new climate you know the
consoles are here we all know him fairly
well it really is it's more about those
third-party developers and publishers
yeah it's interesting i think the rock
band to Guitar Hero fight is more
knock-down drag-out than of and then
Sony Microsoft this year for sure but
other than that you know we really just
wanted to talk about the vibe of e3 this
year you know lots of empty hallways
it's there not a whole lot of people
here yeah I think in a lot of respects
people like d3 because of the spectacle
it was this ordeal that we all went
through together and it really gave the
media
something to take pictures of but the
booth babes and the huge three-story
booths and and 50-foot display screens
that's all gone the games are still here
though in every respect a smaller more
sober and quieter III
well it's not that sober no no no not at
all